yesterday a Muslim terrorists evil loser
to borrow a phrase and uzbeki
immigrant named Sai fool o Sai pause
drove a home depot truck along a bike
path near the World Trade Center killing
eight and wounding dozens in the wake of
this attack the hack news media focus on
the real threat
Islamophobia will analyze where the
trouble really lies then Bradley dev and
Kevin glass and His Eminence Paul Bois
joined the panel of deplorable z' to
discuss Donald Trump Jr's excellent
Halloween trolling more celebrity
groping when will it end never and tax
reform do you remember tax reform I
remember it I'm Michael Knowles's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was pretty bad yesterday I actually
used to live as recently as a few years
ago like six or ten blocks from the
attack from where it happened
fortunately none of my pals or family
roommates were were injured in the
attack but it's a it's another World
Trade Center terrorist attack it's the
first one we've seen in a very long time
you know we know the story we know what
happened
this guy drove a Home Depot truck up the
bike path and killed eight people and
wounded 11 his name is Seif Louis I paav
and President Trump responded quickly so
he called sy Pavan animal he suggested
that we ought to consider sending him to
Guantanamo Bay and he also called on
Congress to end the diversity visa
program I felt this was an excellent
response I thought it hit three very
important points and it was it was Swift
it was you know within hours of the
incident and he immediately addressed
the attack itself we saw in previous
administrations Barack Obama didn't
address the Benghazi terrorist attack
didn't call it a terrorist attack four
days for for many days after the attack
so he addressed it itself he explained
what matters about it now he did get
political he blamed Chuck Schumer for
making America quote import Europe's
problems so forget just identifying it
as a Muslim terrorist attack he's
painting a picture Donald Trump does
this very well with language and he does
it in a way that makes us think that he
doesn't know how to string two words
together but he's painting a picture for
us so rather than saying he said evil
terrorists he's an evil loser even he's
a coward or whatever he's saying we're
importing Europe's problems because we
see Europe we see what happens in Europe
on the news all the time we see the
epidemics of rape we see the constant
terrorist attacks we see no-go zones in
different European countries so now we
have that image I thought it was
rhetorically really smart to do that
then he addressed justice for this
specific individual he didn't gloss over
the individual he said we focused on
this guy and he suggested Gitmo now I
don't know that we can send this guy to
Gitmo he is a permanent resident he's
got legal status here however he's not a
citizen so he came over here
cause of this 1990 law the Immigration
Act of 1990 and the diversity visa
program so you basically just pick
randomly from groups that are not well
established in the United States where
there aren't a ton of them in the US and
then you have a lottery and they get to
come into the country so he's he's
pointing to this guy don't know he isn't
a citizen perhaps we could send him down
to Gitmo and have Swifter justice by
saying that he's pointing out the
trouble with our criminal justice system
one trouble is it goes on and on and on
and it gets hang hung up in the courts
and we rarely see justice dispensed we
see this in the death penalty plenty of
people receive the death penalty very
few people actually get the penalty
itself they received the judgment but
they don't get the penalty itself so
then the third thing that leads right
into is he addressed a policy suggestion
to prevent these attacks from happening
so all the time whenever some incident
occurs very specifically with gun
violence and shootings people on the
Left call for policies that would not
have prevented the shooting so they say
we need to ban high-capacity rounds of
ultra SuperDuper assault rifle things
because they don't know anything about
guns and then we find out as Marco Rubio
pointed out brilliantly in the 2016
campaign that none of the gun control
proposals that Democrats had proposed
would have actually prevented these
attacks in this case however Trump's
proposal would have prevented this
attack because the guy the the evil
loser the terrorists made it through
because of a 1990 law that Senate
Minority Leader Democrat Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer voted for so he
pins Schumer right on as he says you
voted for this law this law allowed this
guy into the country if we didn't have
such a ridiculous law as random
lotteries to bring in people for no
particular reason if we had a merit
based immigration regime for instance
this would not have happened or it's
likely that this would not have happened
really smart obviously though we accused
Democrats of playing politics with
tragedies very often certainly this is
playing politics with the tragedy but at
least in this case we do see a direct
connection between the suggestion and
the tragedy whereas when Democrats
politicize gun violence and
mass shootings we see very little
relation between the policy proposal and
the event itself largely because short
of repealing the Second Amendment
none of those proposals would stop these
mass shootings so Schumer responded of
course the most dangerous place in in
the country in the most dangerous place
in New York is of course the space
between Chuck Schumer and a TV camera so
he said quote I'm calling on the
President to rescind his proposed cuts
to this vital anti-terrorism funding
immediately right he's basically
distracting over here a little
prestidigitation
to use the language of magicians and
talking about random funding when really
we should be talking about the law that
allowed this guy to come into the
country the Chuck Schumer voted for the
mainstream media in typical fashion they
focused on the real threat Islamophobia
salon.com ran this headline quote after
the New York City terror attack Fox News
leans into nationalism and Islamophobia
north country Public Radio says this
headline art as a way to resist negative
images and Islamophobia splinter News
did this NBC News did this from NBC
Muslim Americans brace for backlash
after New York attack they're bracing
that's the story not the attack that
just happened but the bracing that's
going to happen for the inevitable
backlash that inevitably never happens
anchors and writers from MSNBC Teen
Vogue the Guardian on and on and on used
the same as lame' phobia line New York
Times early reporting on the attack
refused to report the language properly
they wouldn't do it they would not use
the phrase Allahu Akbar which is the war
cry that the terrorists shouted when he
had finished his attack instead The
Times used the phrase god is great which
is an okay sort of mistranslation of
that phrase into English their news
alert headline read the motorist yelled
god is great in Arabic officials said
CNN did exactly the same thing their
lower third reporting on the attack said
suspect was yelling god is great in
Arabic the associate oppressed it is in
April when they reported the Muslim
terrorists yelled god is great best of
all here is former journalist
tappers take on the jihadi battlecry he
heard this driver saying yelling Allahu
Akbar Allah Akbar during this incident
which is now leading authorities to
believe that this is as a result that
this is now a terrorism case and I'm
just getting an update now the FBI is
taking over this case because it appears
now that this is terrorism the Arabic
Chanda Allahu Akbar god is great
sometimes I said under the most
beautiful of circumstances and too often
we hear of it being being said at
moments like this it's beautiful the
most beautiful of circumstances that's
the story right that's the first thing
you should say when reacting to the bad
news
the terrorists screamed a beautiful
phrase that has also denoted Muslim holy
war for 14th centuries what he's look he
said that it was used in bad
circumstances too but the first thing
that we should note the important point
here is that the phrase is also used in
nice circumstances sometimes and sure
that might be true contrary to popular
belief the term Allahu Akbar
does not appear in the Quran in the
Muslim holy book rather it appears in
the hadith which reports the actions and
sayings of Muhammad it also doesn't mean
God is great it means God is greater or
God is greatest probably more precisely
translated and sure it's a phrase used
in times of joy it's used in times of
distress joy birth death holy festivals
on and on sort of misses the point
doesn't because Allahu Akbar is the
ubiquitous battle cry of Muslim
terrorists that we've seen for decades
and decades in the notes of the
terrorists who flew the planes on
September 11th we're talking about a
Muslim terrorist attack here here is a
relevant appearance of the phrase Allahu
Akbar in the hadith quote the Prophet
set out for Khaybar and reached it at
night he used not to attack if he
reached the people at night till the day
broke so when the day dawned the Jews
came out with their bags and spades when
they saw the Prophet they said Muhammad
and his army the Prophet said Allahu
Akbar and Khaybar is ruined for whenever
we approach a nation it has tan enemy to
fight then it will be a miserable
morning for those who have been warned
end quote
now Andrew Clavin who never gets into
Twitter spats
by telling him how fun they are he
pointed this out to Jake Tapper on
Twitter he pointed out to tapper that he
was basically saying there are good
people on both sides aren't there folks
the thing that the mainstream media
excoriated Trump for saying in the wake
of Charlotte's vil Tapper defended his
statement anyone further any accused
drew of lying so so drew responded he
said all sorts of things can be said at
weddings and births
it's an inane point that purposely begs
the question the nature of our enemy
Tapper unhinge idli and bizarrely
continued to call Andrew Klavan a liar
but of course he provided no evidence
for that accusation because Jake Tapper
is a Democrat hack who plays a
journalist on a fictional television
program this does however make clear a
key factor in the mainstream media's
recent self-immolation which is their
abusive language we're living in an age
marked defined by language that is not
clear and direct but of euphemisms words
that make harsh things see mild bad
truths appear good and they make clear
events seem obscure Democrats just last
week ran an ad against Virginia
gubernatorial candidate Ed Gillespie
depicting a Republican truck mowing down
children of ethnic minority here it is
is this what Donald Trump and Ed
Gillespie mean by the American dream
Latino Victory Fund paid for and is
responsible for the content of this
advertisement that's the threat huh
that's what we're worried about we're
worried about Tea Partiers we're
worrying about the Gadsden flag flying
on a truck that's not today's Michael
we're gonna see an increase on the
cooldown period of trucks that's right
it you know that's what we're that's
what we're seeing right that's before
our eyes
not quite the American people aren't
stupid
we know that the terrorists didn't
scream god is great we know what war
looks like we know what peace looks like
we know which ideas and vessels for
those ideas threaten our lives and our
civilization the more the mainstream
media insists that our eyes are lying
the less credibility they'll have Scott
Adams has a great piece on language and
terrorism today to which we'll try to
get to later on before that let's bring
on our panel to discuss all of this we
have an all-male panel today
I begged marshalled not to do this to me
but I guess it's my punishment for all
of the potpourri yesterday on the show
so let's introduce of course His
Eminence Paul Dubois we also have Kevin
glass from the Heartland Institute and
we also have Bradley Devlin from the
University of Berkeley the college
Republican head up there gentlemen
thank you for being here Bradley let's
begin with you should we replace this
diversity immigration system with a
merit-based system absolutely I think
it's ridiculous that we're talking about
a diversity lottery system with really
low requirements to enter that lottery
and then once we have all of these
low-skilled immigrants from countries
that don't historically have a lot of
immigrants to the United States we're
gonna then gonna just pick randomly out
of that crop to let them into the United
States with the rate of 50,000 per year
I think implementing the raise act is
gonna be something that's really
important moving forward for the
Republican Party and for the well-being
of this country sadly the route to
passing that doesn't look too good
because Trump didn't use political clout
with his daca policy I think properly
but hopefully we can make some gains and
establishing competition and meritocracy
in immigration policy fair enough
Kevin should we send this guy to Gitmo
can we send this guy to Gitmo and if we
can should we I'm not familiar with the
legal ramifications here if we could
send him again to Gitmo I don't believe
that we should I think that trying him
in the American justice system and
showing that our way of life our legal
system is the best one in the entire
world is the best way to send a message
here fair enough this is an argument we
heard a lot during the Bush
administration that said President Trump
won because of his insistence that
Barack Obama has been weak on terror
that Barack Obama was emptying out
Guantanamo Bay that he gave up generals
back to the battlefield because he was
so nervous about the implications for
alleged American ideals that we have a
base where we put illegal combatants in
war I'm not so sure your eminence
mr. Bois Scott Adams the dilbert guy who
is like the smartest cartoonist ever I
think he had a great column today on the
language of persuasion and he argued
that it's counterproductive to call
these terrorists cowards to call them
terrorists to lay invective on them
because it either plays into their hands
and makes them seem fearsome and that
they struck terror into our hearts or it
just doesn't ring true to call them a
coward he isn't a coward he might be
evil but he isn't a coward he risked his
life thought he was going to give up his
life for this idea system this jihad so
he pointed that's quite effective to
call him evil losers like Donald Trump
does evil losers who are going to hell
because then it introduces a little
doubt into their system you know into
their their view of what they're doing
and it also accurately portrays them
there is there's a little bit of truth
there there's a lot of truth that these
guys are losers and and evil so my
question is should we be changing our
political language in this dialogue from
the language we've used for 25 years and
the harder question is was it was it a
miscalculation for President Bush to
call Islam the quote famously quoted
religion of peace yeah oh well as
Confucius said Michael we have to call
things by their proper labels and
calling Islam a religion of peace is not
calling it by its proper label in the
least Islam is not nor has ever been a
religion of peace there may be aspects
of it that pertain to natural law that
create virtue in the individual
adherence of Islam but Islam as a whole
at it's very substance is about violence
is about subjugation is about domination
that's been true since the age of
Muhammad oh that's true very true today
there's really no disputing that at this
point so the question is now before us
is what do we refer to Islam as or the
partakers of Islam and terrorism do we
call them just evil terrorists do they
call them monsters do we call them as
president Trump has postulated evil
losers I like to think in this matter I
like to think of Screwtape and the
nature of how demons and evil has been
portrayed throughout literature when
it's up in the face of good and that is
really evil by its very nature according
to Catholic perspective is really kind
of stupid and pathetic and and it really
does look like a total loser 8 it talks
a big game it puffs itself up and it's
like we're gonna do this we're gonna
rebel against the order we're gonna
Bible against God but it really just it
looks stupid and pathetic and sad and I
really do think that Trump is definitely
on to something by calling them evil
losers it takes all the power out of
them it they don't look like established
individuals who are carrying out
something great who are a potential
threat they really are just losers and
they will lose in the end
and hopefully he'll look like an evil
loser at Gitmo I don't know maybe maybe
we'll prosecute him here
on your pointed piece it is true when I
was 14 or 15 I read the Quran because I
wanted to I was skeptical of lefties
even then and they kept saying it's a
religion of peace and Islam means peace
and all that and I thought like well I
don't know if I totally buy that let me
see for myself so that I can debate my
Democrat friends and I remember in surah
2 there's a verse it says make not
Allah's name and oath against or an
excuse against your
oats and doing good or acting rightly or
making peace between persons and I
remember that because it sticks out as a
as a passage that calls for peace but
then also they're like a gazillion
passages that call for war and hacking
at people's necks and surprising them
while they pray and not being friends
with the jews and the christians so yeah
it certainly isn't to say Islam is peace
or something is it certainly doesn't
tell you the whole story we have to move
on from these unimportant aspects like
theology and politics to something more
important which is trolling that's what
we should really be talking about all
the time Donald Trump jr. is just really
becoming the troller in chief he tweeted
out a photo yesterday of his little
daughter with a bucket of candy and it
said I am going to take half of Chloe's
candy tonight and give it to some kid
who sat at home it's never too early to
teach her about socialism so Kevin this
was hilarious and I loved it but is it
wrong is it in bad taste for a
politician or political figure to use
their children in a Rifat of their
children to make a point I'm not sure
about that and also I'm not sure if do
we consider Donald Trump jr. to be a
politician or a political figure I mean
he he's not elected obviously I don't
know if he's formally or informally an
advisor to any politician he certainly
weighs in on politics a lot he goes on a
lot of political shows well sure but
like celebrities do that you know
so like Mike Rowe know on Twitter might
say something funny that's political and
he's not a politician I don't consider
this opening his children up really to
politics I do consider it a poor example
of the socialism idea in that you know
Halloween is is at its base holiday
about going over to your neighbor's
houses and asking them for free stuff
and we can even consider that work or
labor or something like that but III
think like you know you go next door and
ask them for Reese's and that's that's
not labor that's and you shouldn't take
your kids candy for that no but Kevin
it's even worse I'm just I'm just
picking
the silly analogy it is it is funny to
obviously teach your kids good hard
lessons when they're young but it's even
worse because you're not going over and
asking for candy you're extorting them
you're saying trick-or-treat that's an
awfully nice house you got there sure
would be a shame if something happened
to it
so in that way I guess it's a lot like
socialism is you actually like agents of
the state they threaten violence unless
you give them something that's exactly
right you know I have had a lot of
debates with some people on Twitter in
the last three seconds about this matter
of the taxes a lot of Democrats seem not
to understand not only taxation but even
what private property is have Americans
have this many Americans rather always
been so economically illiterate or have
they been taught this ignorance Paul
block I would say Michael that's I don't
think they necessarily have been taught
this ignorance I mean they certainly are
instilled with it once they get into
college in the university system but I
think for the most part we just haven't
really instilled like proper values
anymore in our education system so it's
a again I'm gonna go back to a Screwtape
here it's not necessarily about what
they're putting in it's about what
they're taking out so they take out the
good values you know about private
property individual responsibility and
they just sort of leave vague buzzwords
there for people like love and peace and
tolerance and you know an in
distribution of wealth and nobody really
has an understanding and a concept of it
so their mind just thinks in terms of
these buzz buzz words without in any way
thinking about the the weight and shape
of anything true the one percent there's
no talk of how the one percent got to be
the one percent or you know they've
talked about inherited wealth they don't
point out that within two generations 70
percent of inherited wealth is gone and
within three ninety percent is gone they
just use these terms and then kind of
allied over them and try to advance
their point you know Bradley I have been
having many debates with even my friends
on the right some of the Trump skeptics
some of the people who are overdosing on
cough FA and they are saying that it's
wrong for politicians
to troll it's wrong it's unseemly it's
unpresidential it's not right even for
the family or for senators or whatever
to troll their opponents to troll
cultural figures and I certainly come
down on the side of the lols but Bradley
is it wrong for Republican politicians
to troll absolutely not but we have to
be selective in our trolling we have to
understand that the left will always
dominate mainstream media and they will
always dominate the terms of discourse
but we can use those terms against them
when they spout foolishness all over
Twitter I think that picking the battles
we want to fight like fighting against
people who instantly jump to gun control
and trolling those individuals who would
jump to gun control after the horrific
evil deeds that we saw in New York City
is very relevant and important because
not only it shows the evil of the left
that they will forward their political
narrative no matter what but also we get
some laughs and along the way and I
think that we lack a lot of laughs after
everything's been politicized you know
comedy has even been politicized I can't
even watch late-night TV without being
told that if I like my guns I want
everyone else to die or if I want if I
don't want to provide health care for
everyone else around me then I'm some
sort of evil bigot say you already guys
just has nothing to do with that that's
completely secondary right yeah so I
think restoring that that humor inside
the political realm a little bit
hopefully it'll bleed over to sports and
comedy and it's terrifically effective
the two presidents in the century who
used humor as a political weapon or
Ronald Reagan and Donald Trump they used
it very well Reagan was always telling
jokes and he seemed good-natured well
you know well grandpa but really a
revisions Oaks I mean they're pretty
brutally he had told one about how the
Democratic platform you know is
basically a heaping pile of excrement
and many vicious jokes about the Soviet
Union Donald Trump - he's a funny guy I
think that's why people that's why
people can take to him okay we have a
lot more to talk about we have a lot of
celebrity groping
we've got tax reform that we've got to
talk about but if you don't subscribe
you can't see it I want you to be able
to see it usually I try to put up my
all-female panel as an incentive to get
you to come over in a very like
Weinstein II Hollywood way but today
obviously they're not going to work so
instead I'll let you know if you go to
the daily wire.com right now it's $10 a
month $100 a year for a premium annual
membership and you'll get me you'll get
the under Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show yeah yeah yeah whatever no
ads on the website that's cool what
about that though what about that what
is that well this is the leftist here's
tumblr and I don't know if you're under
the misapprehension that Donald Trump is
going to shut down his Twitter account I
don't know if you're under but that
won't happen I don't know if you think
Hollywood is gonna rebound it's not and
you're gonna drown in leftist tears if
you don't have this vessel just safely
store them there isn't going to be any
fallout no no leftist to your radiation
this is a really protective vessel so go
to the daily wired.com right now and
then you can store them hot or cold
always salty and delicious we'll be
right back
there is more celebrity groping going on
I don't even know why that's news I
don't I don't think it actually should
be included on a news and politics
segment but alas we've seen a lot of
headlines more celebrity groping Kevin
Spacey has been accused by more people
of being handsy on set surprising nobody
Dustin Hoffman is now accused of sexual
harassment this time against a female
assistant 32 years ago director Brett
Ratner has been accused of harassment
dating back 25 years this time by six
women obviously Kevin Spacey's
accusations are from 30 years ago as
well and the guy who kicked all of this
off Bill Cosby his accusations are from
decades ago as well now some of these
accusations are relatively minor some
are full-on rape they've been
snowballing now since Bill Cosby story
broke mister Bois why are they all
coming out now the reason why they are
all coming out now is because Weinstein
revealing him set off a big firestorm
and the reason why it's different
between say Weinstein and Cosby is
because Weinstein is an individual
talent he may have a certain level of
power and a certain symbolic status in
the culture but he was not a power
player like the Weinstein a Weinstein
produced I mean countless numbers of
pop-cultural of big movies throughout
the 90s and was a major player in the
Oscars and there was just a level of
corruption that surrounded him that
enabled him to get away with all of
these crimes and now that that floodgate
those floodgates are down it's just it's
open season people are like okay wheeler
Ben Affleck he's too powerful they won't
take him down it's really weird yeah it
is strange that they haven't gotten Ben
Affleck yet but I mean people are feel
very now empowered to speak up they're
like okay let's go out there let's let's
reveal it and some amazing things are
happening as a result I mean Kevin
Spacey
has just been outed I is pretty much a
full-blown sexual predator from the
allegations that are springing forth as
of today so a major change is coming to
this industry and if Hollywood wants to
this from becoming a witch-hunt which it
very quickly can is they need to
assemble basically something like what
the Catholic Church assembled in Spain
during the Spanish Inquisition in just a
good solid task force of of solid
investigators of people who can really
look into this and gather evidence and
dispel any things like rumors or just
like false accusations and really get
down to the bottom and root out the
president but where else are you gonna
see a defense of the Spanish Inquisition
on this show folks that's where we're
gonna do it now they won't take out
Affleck though they won't take him out
everyone else is allowed to fall that
little low house of cards that that was
gonna be cancelled anyway oh this but
Ben Affleck's a super hero and he is too
valuable to them so for some reason
those allegations get swept under the
rug Kevin should the decades that have
passed between these alleged incidents
in the allegations should they weigh
upon our consideration of them at all I
don't think so I think it's a very
complicated question obviously I'm not
going to say that there's no such thing
as women who will accuse powerful men of
things that they didn't do for a number
of reasons but the stereotype of the
gross creepy producer on the casting
couch is a stereotype for a reason that
that's what what has happened in the
movie industry for decades and so you
know it shouldn't just be a thing where
we say that's just the price of being in
the movie industry then you have to
endure sexual harassment sexual assaults
this casting couch type stuff the Harvey
Weinstein type stuff we shouldn't have
to say that so while it could be the
case that there are going to be false
accusations I think we need to take
seriously most of the accusations coming
forward I think we just made a good
point here in that Harvey Weinstein
going down was incredibly powerful to
this moment in in the movie industry
because he was if not the most powerful
man one of the most powerful people in
the movie industry and to say that the
powerful people who may be abusers who
maybe assaulters are not protected by
their power is just wrong there are many
people who are incredibly powerful and
that's why people don't come forward so
yes there might be false accusations
along the line but I think taking
seriously a lot of what's going on is
really important because you know this
is something that happens in the movie
industry and it's it's important to
break those stereotypes it's important
to end this culture of harassment and
assault that has gone on for far too
long that's you know the really the
saddest thing personally that I can
think in all this is I've never mattered
enough in Hollywood to even be sexually
harassed that which which actually isn't
that's not even totally true this town
is so creepy that even when you're at as
obscure an actor as I am you see it
creep in at auditions and at parties and
for example a person who is as powerful
as Terry Crews is who said that he was
approached and groped in a pretty gross
way by a male producer and Terry Crews
is someone who you wouldn't expect
anyone would be attempting to assault
but it probably happens cause diplomatic
yeah we have to move on we have to know
there is one actually one last aspect of
this because it
Woody Allen when this all broke he said
what do you out of all people he said I
fear that this will turn into a witch
hunt Willie Allen who married his
stepdaughter you know and and it
obviously it has were in full witch hunt
mode and the but two things are true
Hollywood is still filthy creepy and
weird
but that is the state that the culture
is in right now and we also see this
level of awareness and probably hysteria
on college campuses they alleged that
there's a massive rape culture that 25%
of women who go to college are raped
that's statistic by the way it's totally
bogus nothing about it you know the DOJ
statistics backs that up at all but you
know Bradley you're on a college campus
you're seeing this firsthand is there a
moral hazard to this atmosphere in which
a person's career can be ruined by
decades-old allegations or a person can
be expelled from a university without
due process
oh absolutely I think Betsy Davos is
absolutely correct in taking back the
Obama era regulations on title 9 saying
that these universities were going to
create kangaroo courts to handle these
allegations of sexual harassment or
assault every fraternity has to go
through sexual assault and harassment
training and how to deal with it and
when they come in they say we're gonna
assemble a panel if anyone's ever
accused of sexual harassment if you are
the victim or the perpetrator and 51
percent of that evidence comes back to
where you're most likely you most likely
perpetrated this sexual harassment you
could face expulsion and I immediately
raised my hand and said what do you mean
51 percent right in the United States
I'm innocent until proven guilty the
burden of proof lies in the prosecution
instead of setting up these kangaroo
courts with bureaucrats were paid six
figures every year why aren't we
providing resources for these students
to take it to the criminal justice
system why aren't we informing
individuals men and women how to get to
the court system how to hire a lawyer
how to file these issues with the police
how to file a rape kit why aren't we
teaching these individuals how to do
that instead we want to handle it
bureaucratically and possibly ruin
people's lives when the proper burden of
proof hasn't been established because
then it would be bad PR for the
university right if it if it goes to the
criminal justice system they can't
control these kangaroo courts and it's
so disrespectful because rape is a crime
it's a very serious crime it's possibly
the most serious crime certainly in
top-2 and to say well it's so serious we
take this really seriously and that's
why we're going to let some random
professor determine the outcome of this
case it's outrageously offensive to
victims and obviously tramples over the
constitutional rights of the accused
let's move on to a topic that always is
getting lost you would think that we
would focus on this because it's the
main legislative item right now but no
one talks about it because it doesn't
fit neatly into twitter that is tax
reform the much long-promised tax reform
Republicans control the House the Senate
the presidency when do we get our tax
reform Kevin you've looked at this a lot
are we gonna get it can
or the Republicans unified enough that
we're gonna get tax reform and if so
what's it gonna look like short answer
no long answer maybe I appreciate the
bad news first and the better news later
exactly you and I must follow different
Twitter accounts because I see a lot of
people talking about tax reform at the
moment yeah if cliff is not in the bio I
don't follow it I don't have anything
I'm interested in the Republicans were
supposed to have put out a firm tax
legislation today if you've checked
Capitol Hill or check to the news wires
they have not they've run into a lot of
different issues some of which are
frankly astonishing to me as someone
who's been following the tax reform
discussion going back many many years
pre Trump obviously pre Obama the
Republicans can't figure out how to pay
for it and obviously the Republicans
during the Obama years committed to
deficit neutrality as kind of a guiding
principle for a lot of their legislation
now they have tax reform and even under
dynamic scoring which is measuring
legislation by the effects produced by
tax cuts obviously tax cuts grow the
economy so at the end you're actually
going to end up with more tax revenue
than you had projected if the economy
grows in the way that you projected to
but even under those rules they're
unable to make up the revenue that
they're losing from what they want to do
all the tax cuts and the policies that
they want to enact so no one can quite
agree on how to pay for it
um well you know Ronald Reagan when
asked about cutting about deficit
spending he said we have to starve the
beast you have to starve the federal
government they're never gonna willingly
cut their spending you need to cut off
their revenue and then they'll cut their
spending why can't we just slash and
burn whenever we would go into a
government shutdown or sequestration or
something they would say well the only
government spending now is non-essential
spending and a rather essential spending
and you would say why do we have
non-essential spending wait wait a
second why don't we when we get rid of
all that non-essential stuff is there
any way for us to just slash a
government spending in a way that
Trump would agree with you know
obviously he's signaled he's not willing
to reform entitlements which are the
major driver of the debt and deficit so
are we just between a rock and a hard
place yeah this has been a discussion
for conservatives and Republicans for a
long time and I think there have been a
lot of pretty persuasive cases made by
some people on the right that starving
the Beast doesn't work we thought that
that was a good plan that the government
would be forced to cut spending if they
just didn't have the tax revenue and
that's turned out to not be right
because in China
just borrow from China right we've been
running deficits for years now we're
projected to run deficits forever and
that's not spurring any action we're not
cutting like you said non-essential
spending in a meaningful way so the the
problem that Republicans have right now
is that yes entitlement reform is
obviously the best way to go to cut a
lot of the spending that's what drives a
lot of the spending but you can't pass
that with only 50 votes in the Senate it
because of reconciliation arcane rules
there you can pass tax reform with 50
votes in the Senate but if you accept
the idea that starving the Beast doesn't
actually work you don't want to just
slash everything that would earn the
economy to the ground it would burn the
government to the ground it would put us
in grease territory it would put us in
territory that has never been seen by a
Western economy I don't like 120 or 4
but I do not mind number 2 that one
sounds sort of interesting to me go on
great so so that's the problem that
Republicans are facing right now in any
meaningful way to pay for what they want
to pay for with tax reform creates
massive political opposition so for
example cutting certain deductions gets
you some money but then the National
Association of Realtors are mad at you
cutting this state local tax deduction
gets you a certain amount of money but
then the Home Builders Association is
mad at you and a lot of those
organizations are large funders of the
Republican Party and some of those ideas
have more merit than others but you just
you have to make enemies if you're gonna
do what the Republicans are planning on
doing and so far it doesn't appear
like they're willing to and everybody
hates deductions until you try to take
away their deductions you know same
thing with subsidies you always hear the
left ranting on about how we subsidize
the oil industry and then when you point
out to them that a lot of those
subsidies are so that poor people can
heat their homes then they say well no I
don't know I wasn't talking about that I
just it's all they all the bad subsidies
all the bad deductions your eminence I
mean I'm sorry going interest deduction
I hated the mortgage interest deduction
until I bought a house now it's great
it's amazing it benefits me and
impressively so it's actually still
probably a good idea to limit the
mortgage interest deduction even though
I am a massive beneficiary of it but yes
once you get into kind of what
deductions go where people start getting
mad and of course we need the the blank
book income tax credit there are a lot
of things that we need to put in retro
actively your eminence does Trump need
this does he need tax reform I certainly
think he needs a legislative victory
Michael he's not going to give it with
um unfortunately Obamacare which was a
debacle and a legislative sin in a house
so I mean I certainly think tax reform
is one of the most one of the best
things that he can get legislatively and
yes he needs a legislative win and tax
reform would certainly be the one but
thus far you know one of the unfortunate
things about Trump's and administration
thus far is that he has not gotten a big
legislative win it's mostly coming from
the executive and of course foreign
policy-wise with what we're dealing with
Isis so it one good you know legislative
victory would definitely I think Trump
needs to check off his box Bradley
you're a college Republican your college
Republican Chairman I was I remember
when I was young like you and at Yale
all of the college Republicans they
didn't really care about social issues
they were economically focused all they
wanted was entitlement reform tax reform
you know very I would say establishment
an establishment conservative
Republicans they didn't want to be
social you know culture warriors because
they wanted to be cool guys they wanted
to fit in and like be cool at parties
you know so myself included a lot of
college kids there ran that typical line
I'm fiscally conservative but
socially liberal do you find that that's
the case at Berkeley right now or have
the culture wars that President Trump
has is exhilarated and is fighting have
they affected college campuses as well
absolutely without a doubt I mean we've
seen a large swing back to social
conservatism I think that it all it all
lies on a pendulum right so the pendulum
swinging back towards social
conservatism and if we look at the first
reports on the younger generations in
the United States we're seeing that they
are the most socially conservative since
World War two I mean this is there's a
lot to gain here with for the Republican
Party even though a majority of young
Republicans are more economically
focused and are more socially liberal
they're actually more socially
libertarian they don't care much they
want lower taxes they want their own
property they want to have their guns
and that's that's mostly the type of
person I am
but we are seeing that shift back
because the Left keeps doubling down on
every culture war we're having and Trump
is choosing culture wars that he can win
and it's it's smart for him to do so and
I think tax reform is actually something
that he can win he I don't think it I
don't know if it'll pass but I think
that he can create a story and a
narrative behind it that can garner
support and he is going for the cut cut
cut Act that's being reported today that
he wants the name of the cut cut cut Act
and he wants to drastically deregulate
small businesses and if you want America
to prosper you have to you have to
support small businesses and you got and
you got to keep it simple just like that
keep it simple stupid cut cut cut well
let's hope it works out panel thank you
for being here very good discussion
Kevin glass first time on the panel of
deplorable z-- Bradley Devlin UC
Berkeley College Republican chairman and
his Eminence Paul Bois
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
no show get your mailbag questions in so
that I can change your life tomorrow and
we'll see you there for the last show of
the week
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jessa
of era and our Associate Producer is
Bailey Lynn the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017